democrats double standard on believing
all women is on full display
and they now all of a sudden care about
due process president biden and nancy
pelosi are both refusing to say that the
new york governor
andrew cuomo should resign after seven
women
accused him of harassment do you think
governor andrew cuomo should resign
i think the investigation is underway
and we should see what it
brings us i said there's zero time
tolerance for
sexual harassment but you're not calling
on him to resign right now
i think we should see the results of the
admit but he may decide and
that was hopefully this result will be
soon
and what i'm saying is the governor
should look inside his heart
he loves new york to see if if he can
govern effectively
speaker and that could be one of the
considerations that he has
and where is kamala harris the vice
president led the liberal crusade
against brett kavanaugh
but now she's nowhere to be seen when
democrat andrew cuomo
is being accused so dana i think that is
the one thing about the current vice
president is she was the leading voice
of believing all women when it came to
kavanaugh in 2018 in fact she went on
television and said the following
she said for a woman to come forward in
the glaring lights of focus
nationally you've got to first start off
by believing her
and at least at the essence of what
she's talking about is real
even if she forgets the facts a little
different story here when it comes to
andrew cuomo andrew cuomo and also tara
reed
if you'll remember that um a little
episode during the campaign
it's interesting to i've been thinking
about this because
she she attains this historical moment
and then what do you do with it nothing
i mean you you you you you have the
table
you don't just have a seat at the table
you are the table um and
and nothing you say nothing i think it
was very
um cowardly cowardly that's a
adjective i'm working on greg um
for gillibrand and schumer to issue a
statement on a friday night
like really it took you that long to do
that and then what did
president biden do today he's on the
side of where most conservatives are
which is that there should be due
process
so what did that do that cut out the
legs of chuck schumer and alexandria
ocasio-cortez because now the
democrats in new york are like okay yeah
we're done with andrew cuomo
and president biden has given the left
quite a bit of what they wanted and
maybe he wanted
in the covid relief bill at some point
is he going to stand up to them
on this or is he going to continue to
demand due process time for due process
but also as nancy pelosi said maybe the
governor will
come to realize that the end of the road
is here
jesse that's the question though is it
the end of the road if polling shows
that the majority of new yorkers don't
think that he should
resign it doesn't have to be
he can play it out as long as possible
if he doesn't seem like he has a lot of
shame
you can tell that if desantis was
accused of the same things cuomo would
have been accused of
pelosi and joe biden would have called
for his resignation i guarantee you that
the democrats have murdered the me too
movement and due process
within probably less than three years
how inconsistent are they i mean if it's
bill clinton if it's kavanaugh if it's
trump if it's cuomo if it's joe biden
himself
they come at it with a totally different
angle so
we know that you can't believe all women
because of tawanna brawley and we know
you can't ignore all women because
harvey weinstein
so here's what you do for a politician
you investigate and then you either
impeach or you have the guy face the
voters it's not that complicated katie
and for the democrats who believe the
sexual misconduct allegations
but don't believe the nursing home
cover-up and scandal
think about this all of the things he's
used in the sexual
scandal the deception the lies the
cover-up
the arrogance the misdirection
he used those exact same things with the
nursing home scandal so that doesn't
really seem that far-fetched does it
but the thing that drove me crazy today
was seeing the new defense
that they're going to start using
they're going to start claiming for
cuomo
it's an anti-italian discrimination
campaign going on how dare they
they're going to compare him to emmett
till and say that he was just flirting
with a white woman
and now he's just being destroyed i
cannot wait till they roll that out
well just don't call chris cuomo fredo
greg
speaking of the cuomo brothers they got
a little bit of
accountability from the media over the
weekend let's take a listen and get your
reaction
well i also wondered john hallman when
when
andrew cuomo used the phrase cancel
culture i thought
oh really now you're now you're going to
use you're going to use a fox talking
point
to defend yourself and you think
democrats are going to stick by you
it seemed like to be a really poorly
uh choice of words
so also at greg over the weekend love
the eric whimple from washington post
was on cnn and said
you know you guys were allowing chris
chroma to come on and talk about how to
love a fest
interview so we're going to play that
now and then you'll react
i would be remiss brian if i didn't
mention cnn's
own huge media story here with chris
cuomo
who covered andrew cuomo and had all
these
wonderful loveathon interviews with him
they suspended the conflict of interest
rule for chris cuomo for those
interviews
yet all of a sudden they've enforced it
again now that andrew cuomo is in the
midst
of an historic scandal that is a major
black eye for cnn
all right greg i don't think cnn saw
that coming
uh i have to give major credit to eric
whimple
you could see on the faces of the other
guests they're going well
that's somebody who really doesn't care
if he gets invited back that's what that
looks like
that's what look that's what it looks
like when somebody isn't interested
trying to get a contributor job he will
actually say something
i just hope that brian stelter was
wasn't wearing pants
in this segment because he likely would
have wetted them
you're not going to mention the bed on
that sand no his hair was amazing
amazing i have a mug from tucker
carlson's show when we used to do
the the quiz during the week with eric
wempel's face on it but and he looks
shocked but actually everybody on that
panel looked like he does
on that tucker mug
well i'm all for telling the truth and
you know i think
getting back to the cuomo situation here
i don't think there's any conflict
between
due process and presumption of innocence
i think the
you know you gotta let him play out but
the bigger issue for me is can he
effectively govern the state of new york
can he do his job
and the poll you mentioned katie which
indicated you know 50
of new yorkers think that he should not
resign
it also indicates that like 48
of those voters say yeah he can do his
job 34
say no he can't do his job but to my
mind
when you look at the elected officials
in new york and washington among the
democrats they're saying they don't
think he can do his job i think that's
the pretty clear message
that's coming from his democratic fellow
elected officials the legislature of new
york has already stripped him of his
power to deal with the covet crisis
he's up for re-election next year that
same poll says a third of those new york
voters say he should not
uh they would not vote for him to run
again so all that's draining his power
he's really
becoming a weakling
hmm that might i don't know if he'll
he'll react to that well
but we'll see an adjective